there's a conversation I very distinctly
remember having in high school another
student said to me while we were in our
sex side class and they were being
completely unironic they said how do you
think people figured this stuff out
before they had sex sad they said
people don't need to go take a class to
know how to have sex the purpose of sex
ed is to tell you what not to do right
you're going to get older you're going
to become an adult you're going to start
engaging in these activities what's
important is that when you were young
when you were developing your parents
ideally had a conversation with you
about what the boundaries are and the
things that you shouldn't be doing
because you're going to figure out what
you can do I don't think it goes that I
don't I think that's that's over the top
Sac said when I was a kid was like here
is a diagram of the male reproductive
organs